body camera video captures back-to-back
officer-involved shootings near Phoenix
Arizona after a suspect wanted for
sexual assault evaded officers in one
city before running into more officers
in another
we won't shoot you keep your hands up
keep your hands up it started on January
6th in Scottsdale Arizona officials
there were attempting to serve a warrant
on 37-year-old Kenneth Hearn for an
alleged sexual assault incident dating
back to October 2022 at the time an
arrest warrant for Hearn was also out
from the city of Mesa
it's got some police in the search
warrant open the front door body camera
video shows a woman answer the door
before she and a small child leaves
safely
can you let me get her
come here it's okay
okay
after that officers yelled to Hearn
calling for him to surrender Candace
come back come to the front door hands
up and empty
the police I'm ordering you to do so we
have a search warrant
come to the front door Hearn then yells
to officers asking not to be shot hey
don't shoot me we won't shoot you keep
your hands up keep your hands up
assuming come out with your hands up and
empty face away from me that's when
officers send a drone into the apartment
seconds later Hearn opens fire
body camera video shows a Scottsdale
Sergeant is hit when one of hearn's
bullets flies through the wall
an officer near the front door then
fires back toward Hearn but misses
after that Scottsdale Police say Hearn
escaped from the Second Story the next
day Phoenix officers caught up with
Hearn in Tempe put your hands up
put your hands up
get your hands up right now
put your hands up body camera video
shows police attempting to arrest her
before he pulls out a weapon that's when
an officer opens fire get on the ground
all right
Phoenix police recover hearn's weapon
before rushing to his Aid he's down
watch he's down he's down watch his hand
gun's away from him Hearn was later
taken to the hospital where he died as a
result of his injuries the Scottsdale
Sergeant shot the day before was treated
and is expected to make a full recovery
both officer-involved shootings are now
under investigation reporting for a long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie